summer solstice 2 13 a.m on june 21st  longest day of the year 14 and a half  hours of daylight it's as far north as  the sun will get all year long let's go  to southwest england let's go to  ancient stonehenge now this was built  thousands and thousands of years ago and  it's a tradition on the summer solstice  that thousands of people will gather at  stonehenge and boy they did it again  today over the last couple of years now  through the pandemic  no one was allowed to gather there but  this is druids and pagans and just  regular visitors that come as the sun  rises it actually  the sun rays  reflect right in the circle of all these  stones and people say that there's an  amazing energy there and so they come to  worship worship the sun and  where they have just healing prayers and  it's a long time tradition they say 6  000 people showed up this morning so  stonehenge nobody had been there for a  couple of years since the pandemic